oh elmo elmo is doing his part to
educate children and parents about the
colvin 19th vaccine
that's right i'm looking at comments
right now it seems like everyone is
celebrating being in their 30s it is a
turning point for a lot of people yeah
it is it really is that's right in a new
public service announcement elmo's dad
louie discusses his worries surrounding
his three and a half year old getting
vaccinated but in the end a chat with
elmo's pediatrician calmed all his
concerns take a look we'll see you next
time bye cheryl bye everybody take care
bye
bye everyone
now daddy have super duper just just
like hell now
you were super duper today getting your
covert vaccine elmo
there was a little pinch but it was okay
emma was really glad to have daddy and
baby david there with him baby david
where are you
i had a lot of questions about elmo
getting the covert vaccine was it safe
was it the right decision
i talked to our pediatrician so i could
make the right choice
i learned that elmo getting vaccinated
is the best way to keep himself our
friends neighbors and everyone else
healthy and enjoying the things they
love oh daddy oh my baby david have a
question
can we have a hug oh come here son uh
everyone loves you daddy i love you too